Li's with us in Indianapolis highly
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show Dave
thank you for thank you for taking my
call sure so most of my life I struggled
with crippling anxiety and depression
but on May 3rd of this year God healed
me Wow I am now taking a look at my
situation and I'm absolutely not happy
with it well where my husband and I are
making about 35,000 a year and that's
with me now working more and we're in a
bunch of day and I I hardly even know
where to start or even like if we can do
much with where we are right now any
time how much that do you guys have
[Music]
sixty seven sixty thousand sixty seven
thousand at least probably more we're
going to go over the numbers exactly
that's Friday okay and what's the sixty
seven thousand on well I know 64 sure of
student loans will start paying on them
next year and and I just also top on my
head I know seven thousand dollars more
that we owe but there's probably more do
you have do you have car payments in one
car right now yeah how do you own it
I think that's down about five thousand
okay that's good okay and what do you do
for a living I am a barista and my
husband is a junior programmer soon to
actually have a degree behind his name
sometime so he's getting ready to finish
a degree in technology yes
next next March he'll have he'll have
this degree okay four-year degree or a
two-year certification program or what
four-year degree okay and in information
systems or information technology where
he's doing database management I believe
yeah and is he going to school full-time
now part-time he is working in these in
the field right now full-time so he's
only been able to do a few classes a
semester yeah so what does he make
what does he make he made right now
about 30,000 a year before taxes my my
job right now doesn't pay much I'm
planning on getting as many hours as
possible but also with where I'm at they
will pay for a schooling for me so I
don't want to leave there if they're
gonna suck up that much okay I'm a
little confused as to why junior
programmers it's about to graduate with
a four-year degree is only making 30
grand right now he's working for a small
company but about you soon he's gonna
start talking to recruiters and find out
what he's worth he's worth double what
he's making the day before he graduates
Wow I had no idea yeah he needs to be
looking at his career right now and be
looking for what it'll look like after
he graduates as well if he is if he's
you know getting ready to be mid-level
with very little experience data
management I mean yeah you got to be
making 60 anyway Wow so yeah you need to
be looking at that that's so one things
you've got to do is you guys have to sit
down and really focus on the income side
of your equation as well as the outgo
side right and then you have to think
about okay what is it that you want to
be doing
ten years from now how old are you I'm
28 okay so you are you going to be a 38
year old person working in a coffee shop
I don't okay no no no it's not about
hope it's about laying out a plan and
executing the plan if you just hope you
will be okay so what do you want to be
doing ten years from now that's gonna
make you 50 to 150 thousand a year I
want to be doing something with
environmental in it preferably fresh
water environmental what science
advanced yeah going through essentially
like helping mostly mostly probably
residential ponds and everything giving
them what they need to actually be good
driving ponds I'm hoping that I can get
into some more of the nonprofit stuff
with larger rivers and lakes and things
and that pays fifty or hundred thousand
dollars a year and there's more than two
jobs in the US that do that I've never
heard of that I'm hoping I haven't
looked into it yeah I think you probably
need to broaden your your game plan here
obviously you have a heart for that but
what I'm asking is not only about your
heart but also what you're actually
going to do with your hours in the day
that are going to create wealth for your
family and that's not just hard and
that's not a non-profit and it's not
that kind of stuff that is what am I
going to be doing as my career field so
I make so much money that I can donate
to things that I am worried about in the
environment or things like that that may
be your better route I don't know you
may be able to work in that field as a
biologist and make $200,000 a year I
don't know I've just never heard of her
I just can't think that there's a ton of
residential pond and vironment implant--
people out there mm-hmm that sounds very
narrow to me and so I want you to I want
you to have a clear path of what you're
going to be doing and how you're going
to get there and how much you're going
to make
then that gives you hope because you're
not going to be doing this on $35,000 a
year that's really not your future your
future is brighter than that on the
income side and then that starts
changing the simple division if you sit
down you say okay we have $80,000 in
debt when you add it all up this weekend
with your husband yeah but he's making
60 and now I'm making 70 oh that changes
the whole equation doesn't it yeah yeah
yeah but making 30 with hope with I hope
oh that's going to get you in trouble in
it I can do that but it's just gonna be
a lot harder yeah and so I mean if you
just simply doubled his income and put
it all on your debt your debt free in
three years
if that's all you do I mean 30,000 a
year for three years is 90 right if we
just double his anymore and I think his
income gonna more than double in the
next three years and I want you to have
a game plan with your career that allows
you to do that as well